Because Saoirse Ronan you all's you want a really good prize
What did you win? I won a trip to Florida when I was a kid
How you want it, I will I won it when I was when I was a kid
And I had never entered into a competition like that before and it was the first day of the summer holidays
When I was I was like 9 or 10 or something and Jeri Ryan who you know
Was this very well-known Irish DJ at home?
He's passed away now
But he was really incredible and his show was like the top shell in the country and Shrek 2 had just come out
That's how long ago was and he was given away this
holiday to Florida and what you had to do was you had to phone in as
One of the characters and Shrek 2 and tell the jury. Why you
Deserved the holiday and I haven't started properly acting yet at that stage or anything
Dad was an actor so it was around sort of like, you know
Improvisers and things like that and I was like, you should go in first just why not?
We had never been on like a proper holiday
God okay
so we got a little notepad like tiny little notepad and we wrote down like a tiny little
script of what I was gonna say just the short little script and they got on and I think I was one of the first
kids on and I and I did it as the gingerbread man and
And so then five days later, he he found up and told me that well you were on The Late Late back in Ireland
They found this clip. So this is this is two little clips put together this it's your gingerbread man. Yeah
Followed by which I read like your reaction to winning is very squeaky voice
Now Saoirse is ten years of age now, which character of you chosen
Oh my I need a holiday
Well, I've got news for you you're going to Florida
Jamie Dornan, hello. Now you don't sleep eat sleep eat. You don't sleep eat. No. No, but you do sleepwalk
listen, I
I that I'm aware of I've slept once in my life. I was about 11 or 12
I
Will go. I've told some shockers on this show before I
woke up and my dad was at the end of my bed and
he said
Morning, Jimmy
Does morning you said your man willing to tell me
Said not really slept look well
You said do you think you slept last night?
Not usually do that. So I thing is them. Well someone's done a poo in the bath
Transoid by a sort of the process of an elimination my sister's working his way down the hole
We met Brad fish rice Zee at the BAFTAs
I think it was um, he came over and he was we were having a chat about something or other and
He was very nice and I introduced him to Dawn and they shook hands
and then we kind of kept on talking and then he started to talk him to somebody else or whatever and
Then after a while I looked down and I realized that she was still holding two of his fingers
I was like we better go to our seats
Okay, and she said forty-one seconds. I said what hello guy held him for
Weeks after those
Kind of awards bitter and um
I'm Bradley Cooper was there very nice guy very kind of personable. Yes who that's home
and
We were leaving
She was getting her phone out of her bag, and I noticed something sparkling
In it. I realized that she had stolen his fork
She was gonna auction it for charity or something but every now to get on home
Hard to feel like a sex symbol when your wife is using another I
Feel too great
You fight your beauty and you often use the medium of hair
To fight you all have some of the worst hairdos in film to really know genuine like a vampire magazine did top 10 worst hairdos
And film I'm definitely free of those
Like Horrible Bosses is intentional and that's
one of the three homes talking about
Movie I love home at the end of the world. Thanks. It's just such a good movie. And you're so good in it. However
That's having hampered. I feel I
Mean, that's a testament. I oughta mess. I was at the time that I actually stood in front of a camera with that
This one in Alexander, which there's worse pictures, they're not from Alexander, that's actually not bad. That was my Doris Day look
You're so not a blonde. I mean, it did seem a big decision to make
Alexander famously blonde he was famously blondie a golden lock two golden lock child, but I'm should have been he should have been brunette
Sure. Maybe she shouldn't have had an Irish accent
From the 7000 reviews I read
Hi-yah what's your name? My name is Eileen Eileen. Yeah, I'm guessing with Marlon
I am from Gerry Gerry up for the north of the country. Okay, and you live they were here
Story here. I live over there. Oh, wait, what are you doing?
Costume design awesome interpretation. Okay, there will be subtitles on Friday
Yeah, but I know ya know so far you're not missing anything
Costume interpretation. Yeah, it's like costume design, isn't it? Fancy fancy? It's fancier Frank
Okay off you go, right so lead-up to Christmas I was back home and
Did you get any of it Chris something about Christmas yeah Christmas that's the only good detail so far
Just pick out words. You'll follow the story say bla bla. Bla Christmas. Bla bla. Bla home
To the shop and I had to get milk and bread
So I was like rollin, all right get the groceries let's go to my boyfriend's dewlap and just pack me up nuni
They park the car so as planned iq boy, you know perfect attainment
silver people carrier just
Casually drift by casual speed. So without hesitation I spread the cross when we look we made groceries
Jump in the back of the car screaming and dump in the back of the chair show them
But taking a mind games Christmas and I had like a scarf up here
Which was my boyfriend turned out to be this middle-aged like I
Don't need to your sound effect
Will shove it in somewhere else my company gonna do it either but
Okay, here's the music
Okay, okay we can't see you now
I think you're one Gary Numan an influence for Walter of the robot
Okay, everyone ready take it away